[Music]
[Applause]
to bring in Mike Florio pro football
talk live co-host and of course
contributor to football night in America
Mike's been writing a lot about the
latest gambling investigation with the
NFL investigating the Colts defensive
back Isaiah Rogers for gambling
violations how did this come about how
did it come to the NFL's attention Mike
well like all of these cases Dan what
happens is when someone uses their phone
and George Orwell
had it right sort of big brother is out
there but we're all carrying big brother
around everywhere we go so even though
Isaiah Rogers reportedly had an account
that was in the name of an associate
he's using his phone everywhere he goes
that phone is pinging and ultimately the
information flows back to the sports
books and they have an obligation under
Indiana Law to figure out whether or not
someone within the Colts organization is
involved in sports wagering and one
thing leads to another and they figure
it out and that's the one big message
that the league the teams everyone needs
to send to the players you will get
caught you're not going to get away with
this and the consequences are dire Dan
it astounds me that that message hasn't
gotten through to the players the way it
needs to and if it has and they're still
doing it boy that's a hell of a problem
for the League what stands out in this
story
well the notion that there's evidence he
bet on Colts games now did he bet on the
Colts to win to cover to win and not
cover to lose who knows and people are
already looking for evidence of maybe
him
half-assing it on a play because aha you
bet against the Colts well let's wait
for the evidence I hope there's full
transparency so we know what he bet on
did he bet on the Colts did he bet on
the Colts to win the cover to lose
whatever that's what stands out to me
because that crosses a new bridge for
the NFL the way I read his statement he
seems to think this is just a situation
where I'll take my medicine like Calvin
Ridley did and then I'll be back I think
it'd be better on the Colts there's a
good chance the commissioner in his
unilateral and complete discretion says
you're done you're gone you're never
playing in the NFL again
I brought this up last hour I don't know
if the NFL brought Calvin Ridley to the
rookie seminar or had him do a zoom for
all of these teams to really understand
he bet fifteen hundred dollars and it
cost him 11 million dollars in salary
which is one of the worst beats you
could ever have in gambling that you
would like baseball tried to do this
with Pete Rose and he wouldn't do it uh
and and therefore it cost him the Hall
of Fame Calvin Ridley's coming back with
Jacksonville I don't know what the NFL
is doing with their seminars with
rookies or with players just to update
them every single year on is there
anything that's changing with gambling
are you allowed to gamble what are you
allowed to gamble on what are you not
allowed to gamble on do we know what the
NFL is doing to kind of protect itself
well yeah the NFL's policy is very
simple for all non-players you can't
wager on any sports for players
you can wager on Sports other than NFL
football but if you do it on team
premises or on team business it's a
violation of the policy which makes no
sense Dan you could stand outside
the front door to the facility pardon me
somebody's at the door my dog's reacting
you can stand outside the door to the
facility like someone's standing outside
the door to my house right now and you
can bet on baseball on basketball but
the minute you walk through the door
it's somehow an affront to the Integrity
of the game that makes no sense that's
one of the problems the policy has flaws
the policy has issues and then the
communication of it whatever they're
doing they don't do a rookie Symposium
anymore because it costs too much money
because you know times are tough now for
the NFL but
coaches get in players faces all the
time how hard is it to go player to
player and say look look you hear about
all these other policies and you need to
follow them but this is the one that can
derail your career here's what you can't
do don't do it or you're done and
they'll catch you why aren't they doing
it of all the coaches in the NFL Dan
Campbell would be the most likely to do
it he's got four going on Five Guys now
suspended so something is is falling
through the cracks as one coach said to
me not long ago if you got enough
players bringing home FS on the report
card it's a problem with the teacher not
the student so I think the league has a
problem the teams have a problem
and they need to get the players to
better understand what they can and
can't do talking to Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host the show the
precedes hours with Chris Sims on
peacock the bills uh Stadium are we
building stadiums and you get a Super
Bowl when you build a stadium Mike
well if it's got a dome yes I'm not
aware of the open air outdoor stadium
quid pro quote Pittsburgh didn't get one
now Pittsburgh would have an issue with
hotel rooms New Jersey got one but that
was the one-time experiment out in the
weather and they got lucky they missed
it by just like a day on each side a
snowstorm so if it was domed yes I don't
think Buffalo is going to get one just
because they're building a new stadium
with State money but if it's a warm
weather location or a dome then they
find a way to give you a Super Bowl for
your trouble
but if they had a dome would Buffalo get
a Super Bowl
you've got the issues with Hotel space
where would everybody stay remember in
Jacksonville all those years ago they
had to bring in cruise ships to make up
for the lack of hotel rooms that's one
of the big problems to having a Super
Bowl maybe I'll get a draft now I don't
know it seems like everybody's going to
get a draft at some point so that's not
some big thing but this was more about a
horribly outdated stadium that needed to
be replaced and the bottom line is this
if the state and local authorities in
Buffalo and Western New York aren't
going to pay a big piece of the bill
there's going to be some other community
that will that's why the Raiders aren't
in Oakland it was never going to happen
in Oakland and here's Las Vegas with 750
million in free money there's always
going to be another Community out there
that's willing to to pay the money to
attract a team and that's the the quiet
leverage that every team has over the
city it's currently in when it's time to
build a new stadium here we are first
week in June what's next on the NFL off
season calendar well the mandatory mini
camps are starting to open that's the
closest thing to real football practice
until training camp and you know you
kind of keep one eye open on the
possibility that somebody's going to get
injured DeAndre Hopkins he's been out
there for a week now I think he wants
way much more than what anyone is
willing to pay him that's why no one has
signed him maybe he sits and waits for
the inevitable injury maybe he waits
into training camp then all of a sudden
somebody's going to have an urgency to
sign in but that's the big name that's
out there that we're all waiting to see
where he's going to land but I think the
fact that it's been 11 days since we
knew he was going to be cut that tells
me his number is a lot higher than
whatever teams are willing to do why is
Aaron Rodgers still trying to litigate
is too strong a word but he's trying to
negotiate this with the media of what
happened and why he's not the bad guy
with Green Bay why why is this still a
topic or he allows it to be a topic
sometimes you can be so smart Dan you're
outsmart yourself and I think that's
what he did here he tried to set up a
narrative that when the season ended in
2022 and he left everything was fine
they want we want you back we want you
back then he goes into his dark closet
and he comes out and he finds out
they're shopping him we had to make that
narrative work and once it started to
show that maybe it didn't work that's
when it becomes well oh they tried to
call me well I only have I only have one
bar on my phone I have no bars on my
phone so I didn't I and it all just
began to crumble so now he's chasing a
narrative that was flimsy from the
get-go as it falls apart and he feels
compelled to to now say oh wait they
decided to trade me because I didn't
return their phone calls well I only
talk to the people I like anyway I mean
the bottom line is it was dysfunctional
he didn't want to be there they had
gotten to the point where they were
ready to move on from him but he feels
compelled to come out of this is the
victim that I didn't do anything wrong I
have no responsibility for this
everybody's got responsibility for this
one team and player and I don't know why
as he moves forward with the Jets he
wants to do this but Dan for the Jets
the warning is tread lightly because all
this stuff he's saying about the Packers
now who knows in a year or two he may be
saying it about you
uh
thank you Mike thanks Dan Mike Florio
pro football talk live co-host and of
course uh NBC football night in America